♪ ♪
>> Laura: AS FOR THE
REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL,
THINK ABOUT IT.
TAKE A LESSON FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY NEVER BREAK RANKS.
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU REPUBLICANS
ACCOMPLISHED BY SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT DURING THE
CONFIRMATION FIGHT OF BRETT
KAVANAUGH WHEN THINGS GOT TOUGH,
WHEN THE MEDIA WERE PILING ON,
REPUBLICAN STOOD FIRM.
DO IT AGAIN HERE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATE TO
DIVIDE AND CONQUER THE G.O.P.
DON'T LET THEM.
THAT WAS MY MESSAGE TO THE
G.O.P. ON MONDAY.
STAY UNIFIED ON ISSUES OF REALLY
BIG IMPORT TO THE COUNTRY AND
GREAT RESULTS ARE GOING TO
FOLLOW.
DESPITE REPORTS TO THE CONTRARY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP EARLIER TODAY
BRUSHED OFF CONCERNS THAT THE
G.O.P. UNITY WAS CRACKING.
>> THE REPUBLICANS ARE UNIFIED.
WE WANT BORDER SECURITY.
WE WANT SAFETY FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: WELL, STILL THERE
ARE SOME LIGHT CONGRESSMAN ADAM
KINZINGER ARE SHOWING SIGNS OF,
WELL, WEAKNESS.
>> IF IT IS AN AGREEABLE BILL,
AND AGREEABLE PREPARATIONS, I
WILL OPEN AS MUCH GOVERNMENT AS
WE CAN.
IT'S A SUPER EASY ISSUE TO
SOLVE.
THIS IS WHAT FRUSTRATES ME OUT
HERE.
WE CAN ALL SOLVE THIS AND IT'S
LIKE AN 80% AGREEMENT WHEN WE
ARE DONE.
IT'S JUST NOBODY WANTS TO GIVE
ANYBODY A WIN OR ANYTHING ELSE.
WE'VE GOT TO GET PAST THAT WERE
GOING TO CONTINUE IN THIS STUPID
SHUTDOWN, IT EASY CYCLE.
>> Laura: HERE TO TELL US
WHERE HIS CAUCUS ACTUALLY
STANDS, THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
G.O.P. VOTE, HOUSE MINORITY WHIP
STEVE SCALISE.
CONGRESSMAN SCALISE, EVEN AFTER
THE SPEECH THAT WAS SO
WELL-RECEIVED, IS THE PRESIDENT
REALLY FACING DEFECTIONS?
>> LAURA, NOT REALLY.
FRANKLY WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS A
GROWING LEE UNIFIED CONFERENCE.
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE CAME LAST
NIGHT TO SPEAK TO OUR MEMBERS
AND REALLY GAVE A VERY
IMPASSIONED PLEA ABOUT WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT.
OF COURSE HE SAW THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: WHAT DOES ADAM
KINZINGER TALK ABOUT?
HE JOINED OTHER REPUBLICANS
TODAY TO VOTE FOR PARTIALLY
FUNDING THE GOVERNMENT.
FINANCIAL SERVICES
APPROPRIATIONS BILL.
ADAM KINZINGER, HE'S KIND OF
TWEAKED THE PRESIDENT ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES.
SYRIA AND OTHER THINGS.
>> KEEP IN MIND THE MEDIA WAS
REPORTING BEFORE THAT BOTH OF
THEIR WERE GOING TO BE 25
REPUBLICAN DEFECTIONS.
GO READ THE POLITICO ARTICLE.
I AM THE REPUBLICAN VOTE
COUNTER.
WE WERE NEVER ANYWHERE CLOSE TO
THAT AND SURE ENOUGH, WE THOUGHT
TO BE A DOZEN OR LESS.
WE ENDED UP WITH EIGHT.
WHEN THEY REPORTED 25 IN THERE
AND JUMPING EIGHT, I'M SURE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE A LOT OF
REPORTS TOMORROW SAYING THAT
THEY WERE WRONG.
IN THE END, THE PRESIDENT LAID
OUT I THINK A VERY PASSIONATE
PLEA YESTERDAY ABOUT WHY WE ARE
IN THIS.
>> Laura: THERE WAS A MEETING
TODAY THAT YOU ARE AT WITH THE
PRESIDENT, AND CHUCK SCHUMER
COMES ON TV AND SAYS THE
PRESIDENT -- IT'S HIS FAVORITE
WORD, TANTRUM.
IT'S LIKE PSYCHOLOGICAL
PROJECTION.
>> NOBODY HAS HAD MORE TANTRUMS
THAN CHUCK SCHUMER.
WATCHING YOU NANCY PELOSI LAST
NIGHT, THE GREENACRE SEGMENT
THEY GAVE, IN THE END, THEY HAD
NO REBUTTAL TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID IS A CRISIS OF
THE BORDER.
WHEN YOU SEE NANCY PELOSI AND
I'VE BEEN IN THESE MEETINGS NOW.
THIS IS THE THIRD MEANING
WITHOUT IN THE LAST WEEK.
NANCY PELOSI WILL START OFF BY
SAYING I AM FOR BORDER SECURITY.
THE PRESIDENT WILL SAY OKAY, HOW
CAN YOU SAY YOU'RE FOR BORDER.
SECURITY.
I NEED FUNDING FOR BORDER
SHE WILL NOT AGREE TO A DIME.
LAST WEEK, THE ONLY TIME SHE'S
EVER PUT IN AN ALTERNATIVE ON
THE TABLE WAS WHEN LAST WEEK SHE
JOKINGLY SAID SHE WOULD SUPPORT
A DOLLAR.
ANY AMERICAN OUT THERE, NO
MATTER WHAT SIDE OF THIS DEBATE
YOU'RE ON REGARDING IMMIGRATION,
IF YOU REALLY THINK A DOLLAR IS
A SERIOUS ARGUMENT AND PROPOSAL.
WE ARE IN A SERIES NEGOTIATION.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THE EXPERTS
HAVE TOLD ME TO GOING TO TAKE
$5.6 BILLION TO SECURE THE
AMERICAN BORDER.
WHAT'S YOUR ALTERNATIVE AND SHE
SAYS A DOLLAR.
>> Laura: KAMALA HARRIS FROM
TONIGHT, WE HAVE A SOUND BITE,
THIS IS HOW THE LEFT IS DEMAGOGY
IN THIS ISSUE.
>> START TALKING ABOUT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND LATINOS
DON'T WANT THIS.
THIS STUFF HAPPENING.
I MEAN, WHAT WAS THAT SUPPOSED
TO BE ABOUT?
TELL ME THAT.
IF NOT ABOUT INSERTING RACE IN A
WAY THAT WAS INTENDED TO CREATE
FEAR AND DIVISION.
>> THE FEAR AND DIVISION IS
COMING FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE TIRED
OF SEEING DRUGS BAR ACROSS THE
BORDER.
OFFICER RONIL SINGH'S FAMILY,
THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE LIKE
THAT.
I'VE SEEN STORY AFTER STORY,
CALLING SOME OF SHARED STORIES
WITH ME ABOUT DEATHS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED IN THEIR DISTRICTS
ABOUT PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY.
WE BRING OVER A MILLION PEOPLE
INTO THE COUNTRY LEGALLY TO SEEK
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER ILLEGALLY THAT
ARE HERE TO DO BAD THINGS,
DRUG DEALERS, TERRORISTS, LAST
YEAR I.C.E. AGENTS SAVED OVER 90
YEAR I.C.E. AGENTS SAVED OVER 9C
YEAR I.C.E. AGENTS SAVED OVER 9I
YEAR I.C.E. AGENTS SAVED OVER 9D
YEAR I.C.E. AGENTS SAVED OVER 9R
YEAR I.C.E. AGENTS SAVED OVER 9M
YEAR I.C.E. AGENTS SAVED OVER 9H
YEAR I.C.E. AGENTS SAVED OVER 9N
TRAFFICKING.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO SAY TO
THOSE OF 900 KIDS?
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT SIGNED
LEGISLATION TODAY, ANTIHUMAN
TRAFFICKING LEGISLATION.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS COVERED
AT ALL ON THE NETWORKS.
IF IT WAS, I MISSED IT.
>> THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE MORE
TO TRY TO STEM SOME OF THE TIDE
OF THE BAD THINGS THAT ARE
COMING ACROSS OUR BORDER FROM
DRUGS TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
OVER 30% OF ALL THE WOMEN IN THE
CARAVAN HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED.
>> Laura: WHERE ARE THE
FEMINISTS?
>> WHY DON'T THEY CARE ABOUT
THAT?
IF YOU DO BECAUSE IT'S NOT REAL.
>> BY THE WAY, CHUCK SCHUMER
VOTED FOR A SIMILAR WALL IN
2006.
WHERE IS THEIR INDIGNATION ON
ALL THIS?
>> Laura: WAS THE PRESIDENT
PETULANT TODAY?
>> THE PRESIDENT NEVER BANGED
HIS -- HE WAS VERY CALM, TRYING
TO GET A SOLUTION.
NANCY PELOSI NEVER WANTED TO PUT
AN ALTERNATIVE ON THE TABLE.
HE LOOKED AT HER AND SAID YOU
KEEPS SAYING YOU WANT TO OPEN
THE GOVERNMENT UP AGAIN.
WHAT IF I OPENED UP FOR THE NEXT
30 DAYS.
THEN OF THEIR DUTIES, WILL HE
SUPPORT THE WALL?
WITHOUT BLINKING, SHE SAID NO.